and finally new rules someone has to
explain to America's police that the
purpose of the body cam isn't so you can
upload your beatings onto YouTube when
did punching someone in the head become
a law enforcement technique the cops
need to make up their minds they do a
Riverdance on your skull and then when
they're putting you in the car they say
watch your head
[Applause]
we need to stop saying most cops are
good like we know that to be true I hope
it's true but I need some evidence
unlike cops the bad ones not the good
ones problem is again we don't really
know what that percentage is that's the
question I'm asking tonight if most cops
are good why are there so many videos of
them being bad just in the last month
we've seen just a few bad ones beating
the suntan lotion off a skinny girl in a
bikini completely atypical officers
mercilessly whaling on a homeless guy in
Oregon and totally non representative
policemen beating a black man in Arizona
that's a lot of videos of guys who
barely exist doing [ __ ] that hardly ever
happens not to mention the Milwaukee
Bucks sterling Brown getting tased for a
crime white people can't even imagine
existing while black this is why NFL
players want to take a knee not because
they hate the anthem
[Applause]
now in the cops defense the woman in New
Jersey did have an open container of
alcohol the homeless man was making loud
noises and the man by the elevator
looked like he was quote preparing for a
physical altercation which apparently
means he was standing up it's not
getting a speeding ticket in a parked
car because your flame decals look fast
seems to me we need a me to movement for
the police if Garrison Keillor had to go
away for putting his hand on a woman's
back perhaps we should decide what
should happen when two men pin a woman
down in the sand and punch her in the
face because I'm sensing a power
imbalance here there's obviously a lot
of rage
that police work brings out in a person
and I don't doubt for a moment that it's
justified and that we need to do more to
help officers find better ways to
channel it but we also have to call men
who wail on the defenseless while their
buddies hold them down what they are
cowards
84% of cops say they've directly
witnessed a fellow officer using
excessive force and 61% say they don't
always report serious abuse this thin
blue line stuff has got to go away it
can't be that it can't be the duty of
every American to say something if they
see something except the people whose
job it is to do something when when cops
ask minorities why they don't snitch on
their own minorities have every right to
say you first
and stop just stop defending the
indefensible they're always reviewing
these videos as if they're ghost hunters
looking for signs of a poltergeist the
only thing you need to review is your
hiring practices we we need we need
better psychological screening to weed
out the people who become cops as
payback for highschool because that's
always the real crime isn't it attitude
not being instantly deferential we need
to ask the question of the wrong type of
people becoming cops it's a fair
question
the police attract bullies like the
priesthood attracts pedophiles like
carnivals attract meth addicts look I
know there are good cops I know some
personally I used to buy drugs off one
great guy no I I do know some cops I do
know some who do their jobs like total
pros and it's true there are no viral
videos of an officer putting his life on
the line every day for years so I get I
get why cops are so often ready to
explode America is a nation that current
statistics show is 23.6% scumbag
and that's who cops deal with every day
thieves pimps Road ragers gangbangers
people who lock their kids in cars
perverts jerking off in books doors Shia
LeBeouf but if you expect nice don't be
a cop be a Mountie police work
it's like proctology [ __ ] come with
the job it doesn't give you the right to
abuse people remember you're a cop not a
flight attendant